yeah thank you guys so much for being
here for just a completely random
completely impromptu live stream
if uh some of you are new here you may
be stumbling in because you're seeing me
play a game and you may not be familiar
with our YouTube channel but we normally
do a Tuesday night
show where we really talk a lot of
Hogwarts Legacy
all right let's see there we go
oh you got a pronunciation here okay
let's see that's 10 total gifteds from
Elwyn that is amazing I saw Elwyn
gifting in expecto goes live stream
today as well so that is awesome
it's pronounced huh
nepheel for future reference interesting
ha hanafield
all right I think I'm actually getting
close to the end of this game and I
gotta tell you guys I am loving it so
far I've just been going like at a very
slow pace
because as you guys know I have a lot of
I have a lot of things going on
and these enemies actually just made it
to these enemies
the last time I played so not really
sure yet if there's a trick to be able
to get rid of those uh
Shields that they have going
but oh let's see I don't want yeah
Megatron Collider
that one is pretty powerful but you know
what I only have 10 of that one still
lightning rod
a feel I'm gonna have to try to remember
that
all right you know what game audio is a
little bit low for me I'm just gonna
turn it up on my end
all right nice
okay that's perfect
that's perfect for me let me know how
everything sounds to you guys hopefully
it should be uh my audio should be the
same as always but where we've got game
audio in here as well I don't know what
that's like
but yeah I have just I have so enjoyed
this game
and it's not a very long game from what
I've heard but I'm just I've just been
completely taking my time with it not
getting in a big rush
level up two nice let's go
janessi don't think you finished it
I I definitely want to finish it it
might even be a game that I try to get
the platinum trophy in
just adjusting my oh wow
just in my microphone a little bit here
so I can lean over
just a bit more to see my screen here
all right who is that is blasting me oh
that guy way over there okay
all right so
I could try and take him out negatron
collider I kind of see this as a
oh wait it's not actually doing anything
to him
all right let's go over here and grab
this first though
and forgive me guys I'm gonna try to I
will try and check in on chat
but I am so used to when we do our live
streams and we have just like talk show
which is what we normally do I'm just
constantly in tune with chat so if I
don't respond as quickly as I usually do
don't get upset I promise I'll I'll
glance over every now and then this is
just a completely different feel it's
been a while since I've done a I know we
did a little bit of Harry Potter Chamber
of Secrets last week but
we had so many technical issues we
didn't really get to play a lot of the
game
no way we've got two Elvish names in
here
oh that is awesome
as I just take that right in the face
right there
you know I have developed a habit of not
finishing games and it it pains me to
say that
oh yeah this is kind of like a boss they
don't let you get some early hits in on
him but when I was younger I mean when I
wasn't doing the YouTube thing and
before I had kids man every game I
started every game I started
if I as long as I enjoyed the game I
mean it was a definite oh wow that did I
only did four percent damage my shatter
blast this little uh kind of grenade
like weapon right here
that was the first thing I upgraded
and it is pretty powerful
see how fast it's taking him out
I already got him at 60 but now he's
called in the reinforcements
all right we're still full health so
and we're about to run out yep in fact
we just did all right let's get Mr
fungi out here
[Music]
as I like to call them
and then let's also get the globe of
Doom I've only been using this one
recently
this is gonna get some people out here
to to help out and do battle
do battle for me and then let's go
executors kind of like a shotgun
foreign
executor and all these guys out I'm kind
of just
tanking the damage here
there we go all right he's taken out
let's see if they send reinforcements
though
in big trouble all right reaction
assassin here in the house as well what
is up my friend
I don't know that I've ever done just
a game stream on YouTube this might
actually be my first time ever doing
that
I mean like I said last week we kind of
did a hybrid we did we started off the
stream doing Hogwarts Legacy discussion
and then we shifted into a Chamber of
Secrets PC chat
or not PC chat but uh PC gameplay okay
we've got two options here we can go
left or
we can take this over here let's see
what the map shows all right so our
objective right now we need to reboot
the fixer
and
if we go
let's see
I mean let's see how okay if I'm
positioned this way
but then there's also this okay this I
think I could get back from over here
so I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try this one first I think
actually wait how do I even use this
thing
hold up hold up hold up I completely
forgot how to use this thing
okay it's not sprinting it's not the
dash
all right let me just do this one then
this game's pretty good about letting
you kind of explore and get back to
other areas so I think we'll be fine I
think we'll be able to do that again
Harvest Moon I see you guys talking
about Harvest Moon I actually never
played Harvest Moon I heard a lot of
good things about it
but I never played it did get into
Animal Crossing though
okay so I think we're on the other side
now
was he turned off because yeah I never
uh I never played Harvest Moon
okay let's grab this right here
what other games you see elwyn's talking
about Half-Life portal Diablo Guild Wars
Torchlight okay I'm a big fan of portal
I have tried Diablo and couldn't get
into it I I get the appeal though I
definitely get the appeal
but it just I don't know I found it a
little too it's a little too repetitive
for me but I love all the portal games
Portal games are great
Tom Snipes what is up man
welcome yeah I'm I didn't get into the
ratchet games like when they first came
out
but I played
I would say I've played probably half of
them now
and this one I mean they're just a blast
you know they're just like pure
pure gameplay fun I mean and this one on
PS5 it looks like a Pixar movie the
graphics are incredible
that Dude Looks Like The Iron Giant
yeah Pixar style animation with just fun
gameplay you know they're not they're
not the most Innovative they're not
doing something crazy that's never been
done before
it's not some epic story it's just a
solid game they're just solid games
okay I just botched that I thought I was
pressing to the right apparently I
wasn't
grinding wait why is it not oh
okay
yep you gotta jump here then jump back
then jump here
oh this is awesome I mean how can you
not love this
I had no idea this is gonna happen I
picked a good scene to stream though
right
oh I might have pressed it too soon nope
we're good we're good we're good
oh that's so cool
all right get the little spin going
oh my gosh a Toy Story game with this
graphics
dude the old school I think it was
oh was it like the Sega Genesis Super
Nintendo era there was actually a really
good Toy Story game
at least in my memory it was a good game
oh I don't know if I was supposed to do
that if I just found the secret or
something
oh got the little Crystal right there
and another one coming up here on our
right
[Music]
I have used the photo mode a lot in this
game too
oh my gosh
was not expecting that
this little spin going again
oh dude this is crazy
imagine this is like the very last
mission of the game
and I stream for like 20 minutes
finishing the last mission
oh oh no wait did I mess something up
nah I think that was supposed to happen
okay
all right come on Clank you gotta help
us out here
yeah
I am thick British World Cup needs
better graphics
oh yeah Tom this one's this one's really
good I've been really impressed so far
I think it's only on PS5 though I don't
know if you have a PS5 I don't think
this one was cross gen with PS4 as well
I could be wrong though there's a lot of
the Sony first party stuff has been
asked me to protect them wait what the
heck did I miss he's on our side now
I should put captions on
very many and you became distressed I
never saw the movie burrito
I never saw the movie
[Music]
I think it's on Netflix
[Music]
can you fix this okay did anybody catch
why he just suddenly befriended us right
there
what it what did I miss I was talking
over the game so you guys probably
didn't hear it either but
he just randomly decided oh we're good
it's all good
should be I who is thanking you we gave
you the gift of Hope okay
I think it's just PS5 Clank said
something he missed it too right let's
get back what did you say
oh I hope all right now
okay I think we're done with our
objective
you did looks like you're a natural even
in my Dimension I mean just just look at
this like even the
what I love is when you put it into
you put it into photo mode here
I mean you could just really set it up
for some
some awesome shots
this lady over here Mrs zircon
I've taken a lot of photos in this game
just so good all right let's see if we
got any new things that we unlocked here
[Music]
okay the buzz blades cold snap okay so
I've had these unlocked for a while I
haven't bought them yet because I'm kind
of just waiting to see
these two sound really good just like in
name alone I can't actually see what
they do yet but they're coming soon so I
don't want to spend everything I have
yet
Hogwarts Legacy oh my gosh the photo
mode for real
it better have one right I feel like
that's
that's a must that's a must okay we
unlocked some new upgrades for lightning
rod I actually used this one quite a bit
so
let's go ahead and upgrade these all the
way we still have 12.
wait auto aim oh that's pretty cool
void Repulsor that's a new one I got
that one's like a little Shield that
also absorbs energy and then can
to bounce it back to them
yeah Black Widow I've
I can't get over the grab the graphics
are so good and I've taken my time too
I've not rushed through it at all
honestly I think obviously in hours
Eldon ring is a longer game but in terms
of actual days that it took me to play I
think I platinumed Eldon ring in a
shorter amount of time than I played
have played this game because it's one I
don't know it's just one that really
lends itself well to you could just pick
up and play you could just jump right
back in the menus and sort of the
overall the way the structure of the
game is you can easily jump back in and
you're not going to be totally lost
all right so I don't want to leave this
planet just yet I bet my objective yeah
Escape so we've got two Collectibles
down there in the bottom right that we
still didn't find and if I hit this tell
actually I should probably go to this
teleporter here
and then go back over there because I
know there's a way for me to use that
little
launch pad thing that I just
for some reason forgot how to do
it yeah high IQ Warrior exactly right
and Nico I saw you're a PC guy I don't
know if you saw my latest uh
in my latest newsletter I had a had a
small rant on PC and my my frustrations
with
trying to actually transition to be more
of a PC Gamer
and just like every time I try man I
constantly have issues it's like all
these little nagging issues yeah Tom I
love the Uncharted games played played
all of those
Last of Us is actually my favorite game
of all time which is you saying
Uncharted made me think of naughty dog
now this section over here
why did the music just speed up I found
this section earlier and I cannot figure
out what it leads to it's kind of just
this random area
and you can't really like I'm hitting
like invisible walls right here you
can't go anywhere else
but that's it like there's there's
nothing else to do in this area so I
thought maybe you have to I don't know
release these or something nothing
happens so I don't know if there's
something we're gonna find later on in
that area
but for now I think I'll go back
yeah let me just try to get to that
teleporter
wait why is it not okay there we go now
it's locking on
you chart a PC in October yeah I knew it
was pretty soon
dude can you imagine that is gonna look
just ridiculous
it's gonna look so good wait what I
didn't even see that
did not even see that Gap right there
ship shall we there it is okay saw at
that time
Castlevania for Halloween
which one there are so many of those
games
so many Castlevania games I
wait what are you guys talking about 10
minutes at least 10.
oh I missed the rift I bet that takes me
to a secret spot too
that's probably gonna take me okay so we
gotta remember that we need to go back
on this again
I love these right here
yeah we definitely need to take that
again and and remember that Rift
okay I definitely remember doing this
part
let me go down here and then it's kind
of gonna
shift forward we gotta wait a second
okay now I can lock onto that
pre-order Collector's Edition from uh
from GameStop for PC for you talking
Uncharted
or are you probably talking uh I bet
you're talking Hogwarts Legacy
I don't think Uncharted has a
collector's edition
all right
oh okay L1 right there all right I'm
trying to get back to yeah maybe if I
take this portal
that'll actually get me to where I'm
wanting to go
and so yep okay we're making our way to
the portal here
which uh which Castlevania game though
burrito
there's so many good ones
yeah I have Miles Morales for PS5 I
I want to live stream that one at some
point too I've heard that's a pretty
short game overall so that might be a
fun one to live stream all right let's
take this portal oh no that's gonna warp
me to little junk Town though which I
I'm pretty sure is back here
uh let's go ahead and take it anyway
because even if it yeah that's what I
thought but that's fine because what I
want to do
is I want to take that little uh
take this right here
I love the lightning bolt one
but my favorite my favorite still is the
shadow blast watch this watch this
and he just oh so satisfying
okay so first hit doesn't take them out
but
takes two and they're done
and then I I've upgraded the regular
glass pistol quite a bit too
so for those of you in here who are uh
Hogwarts Legacy fans I've talked a lot
about
how if they do a spell wheel
that it could really take inspiration
from this game because look at all these
weapons
look at all these weapons and then if I
hit R1 I'm I've started another page too
so I don't really love the multi-page
aspect of it I think I would rather them
go to smaller little sections here and
keep them all on one Circle
but I do I really like this system and
then also if you look in the bottom left
right now
you can also map things to the d-pad as
well so you could put like some of your
most used ones like see I'm just cycling
between these four right now you put
those there on the d-pad and then you
can keep all your other ones here so I
feel like that would be a pretty quick
way that you could still switch between
them
lock onto this one launch me again
hey Jessie how's it going Gotham Knights
uh honestly it's not on my radar
if it if it gets really good reception
like if a lot of people are talking
about it and enjoying it I might give it
a try yeah
the big one I'm looking forward to is
God of War that that's the big one of
the year that I'm looking forward to
okay I think we're back to the spot
or we're getting close to where I want
it to be
all right so
okay
yeah this is where we just were
and then we take this over here
all right not this way but this way up
here
and here it is okay what what am I doing
wrong
and another teleporter okay that's good
if we want to get back right away
why okay what am I forgetting am I
supposed to
I can't
remember oh my gosh
because if I just jump here
think I mean what what the heck let's
try it
oh
oh I think hold on if I if I do the
little glider a little bit longer I
might actually make it
I hope ratchet had an easier I'm
building a new dimensionator
oh that was even worse
dude there's something that you're that
you can do with these things to launch
you
oh there it was there was there was okay
okay got it got it got it it's R1
I did nice all right here we go
oh my goodness all right I definitely I
like using lightning rod on these guys
because they're usually crowded up in a
little pack together
so you can get and get a lot of them
really quick all right so what was the
point of this area over here let's kind
of look around here
we've got all those portals around us
you really not jump up there
what okay no there's gotta there's gotta
be
there's gotta be something here we've
got two Collectibles that we still
haven't found one of the big
uh the little golden screws there
and then the other thing I can't
remember what it is like ratchets uh
ratchet's head the symbol for ratchet's
head
the new Pokemon games
I still haven't even played RCS I I'm
ashamed I I really am ashamed of my
backlog you guys
it is it is just it ridiculous at this
point I have got so many games to catch
up on okay
why can I not go in there
can I not go in there
okay hold on if I go over here again
oh it's okay wait there it is
wait wait wait oh
it's not letting me warp into them
okay there's there's got to be a secret
here there's gotta be something that
we're not doing right
oh my gosh we have two Logans what the
heck
you gotta be asking the other Logan
because I just got here
hello second Logan
Channel member Logan welcome
okay but are you sure there's nothing
else over here to explore
I guess not I I guess not I guess we
can't actually get through those portals
all right I just want to make sure I
wanted to try and explore everything
because we still have those two items
which it's not the end of the world if I
don't find them actually we know where
one of them is
let's go back to junktown we know for
sure we know where one of them is
because of the uh
remember when we were riding the rail
and it popped up
so oh yeah I don't want to fight this
guy again
just gonna run past them
all right here we go
okay
sorry chat I'm not gonna look at you for
a few seconds I want to make sure I
don't miss this one
it's a little portal that appears off to
the left
here in just a little bit
all right it's coming up soon now
oh okay I thought it was back there it's
not there
all right not here
it's when you're kind of out in the open
I hope we gotta hop this way though and
back here
all right then back here there it is
nice okay all right
okay so it put us on a completely
different track
and wait nothing happened now we're back
I think we're back on the regular one
now
maybe maybe not we'll see yeah oh yeah
we're definitely just
on the regular one now
well then
that other golden screw is very well
hidden
is very well hidden all right well we
can just go back oh
almost messed up right there we could
just go back to the ship then because
I'd rather proceed to the next level
than worry about
too much exploration here
because it doesn't really show it on
your map so
I think I'll go back after probably
after I've beaten the game and then go
back and try to get all of the
all the Collectibles that I missed
all right okay that's where we we don't
want to jump back on that one
oh my gosh the Disney all the Disney
Pixar games that Insomniac could make
yeah for real
they would look so good
all right hold on where the heck am I
supposed to go
right here
or no wait that's where we
this is where we arrived
I'm pretty sure it's over here oh yeah
there it is there it is
yeah Avalanche has the experience with
the Disney games too
Black Widow can't wait for Hogwarts
Legacy I know right somebody was asking
earlier if I'm gonna stream it we were
talking about that last night on the
live stream
I'm torn I'm torn I will definitely be
streaming it at some point I guess the
part I'm torn about is when if I'm gonna
be streaming it live day one
I had a lot I've already gotten a lot of
feedback in the comments on the VOD of
that video of people saying no no you
definitely need to just do your
your reaction first like my my initial
reaction where I record my gameplay and
it's not live and so I just post it to
YouTube as as a let's play instead
okay how do we get back to the ship
uh are you gonna get me back to the ship
I don't think you are
maybe you will though yeah you will
you're definitely sending me back to the
ship right here
all right nice okay let's do one final
scan just to make sure we don't see
anything obvious that we missed
there are two things though that we
missed here so we'll definitely have to
come back to this one at some point
how's it going Psalm exclamation point
credit card number
no I don't I don't think that is a
uh I don't think that's command we'll be
adding
all right so we gotta go back to this
planet here build the dimensionator the
lombax is combine the phase quartz with
the newly built dimensionator to save
the Omniverse all right so let's look at
the planets we have so far so there
we're actually missing two things there
as well
on that planet we're just missing one of
the gold bolts
there oh they were missing quite a bit
on that planet and that's actually where
we're
oh that's the one we're heading to yeah
so that makes sense that we don't have
anything there missing three on that one
two on that one
two on that one and then two gold bolts
on that one all right so we'll have
plenty to collect even after we beat the
game
done with your homework Jake nice good
man good man
getting the homework done oh my gosh
just look at that planet
this looks so
amazing these graphics
and saving the universes are you nervous
about meeting ratchet what
that's right they haven't met this whole
game
once we build the dimensionator he will
help us find Dr nefarious
uh retro I'm just curious how long has
it taken to build your community
that Logan that is a
that is a good question
all right
okay wait hold on I'm trying to let
Ribbit finish talking here I think she's
done now
you know what let's go ahead and turn on
I'm going to turn on subtitles because
since I'm talking a lot
that way people can still uh
still see what what's being said if they
want to
so all right let's I'll give you guys uh
an overview here so I started streaming
back in
I don't even remember the exact year now
but I would say it's it's like five five
plus years or so ago it was when
fortnite really started to take off when
everybody started streaming
when everybody started streaming that's
that's when I started streaming and and
I started streaming on Twitch and
initially you know I played I played
some fortnite but I was under no
illusions that I was gonna
build some huge Community around
fortnite it was more just kind of a
trying things out to see to see if I
enjoyed it see if I liked it and if you
guys are wondering why I keep just
running around I'm kind of just
exploring this area I want to make sure
I'm not missing anything here
all right I think we're
I don't think we can do anything with
this ship yet over here
so I did that for probably six months or
so and thought you know what let's go
ahead and push for
twitch affiliate and for a long time
like twitch partner was my goal I
thought it'd be cool to be a twitch
partner
and I I mean I built a little bit of a
community there but
I mean most of the time my streams were
five five to ten people you know fairly
small Nico will tell you Nico's one of
the ogs dude Nico was there
all right let's see if we unlock the new
yes we did
warmonger 30 000 all right let's hit the
preview on this
I love these little uh descriptions here
from Zircon Jr
to Rocket
pretty simple right okay so it's a
rocket launcher
I'm good with a rocket launcher
I think I'm doing a bite I think I'm
definitely gonna buy this one
see this is why I've been saving
because I see I have 42 000 right now so
I couldn't if I'd been buying these I
wouldn't have had enough and honestly
these just didn't look all that great oh
my gosh oh that one's still
all right fine I'm I'm doing the war
Monger though I'm doing it
I'm doing it
all right now let's see we unlocked more
upgrades
you know what I'm gonna go just
immediately start upgrading the
warmonger
Aladdin open world oh my gosh The
Aladdin games on uh the Super Nintendo
Genesis era
I guess it was really The Aladdin game
but it was awesome it was a good game
it was a good game
but back to the question it's it's a
really long answer really long answer
but um so the twitch thing I probably
stream for two or three years regularly
like three times a week man and it
and I I loved it I really did I loved it
and I realized this is something that I
I feel like I'm
I'm talented at it I feel like I enjoy
it
so you know if it's something I could
build a little build a community make a
little side income out of with the dream
obviously being to do it full time we'll
see what happens well there was a point
where I was actually starting to think
about man should I add a fourth night of
streaming per week
and then I came across this video
talking about it was a Harris Harris
Heller video talking about working uh
smarter not harder
and I felt like dude I felt like I was
like man I am working so ridiculously
hard I don't know which way I should go
should go through here let's see where
this leads first are you guys good
you're friendlies okay you're Friendly's
nice
and basically it was a video just about
how if you you know to build a community
it's really you're building a business
is what you're trying to build and so
you oh my gosh hold on this is an epic
epic moment here guys epic moment hey
hey first time meeting yes ratchet and
rivet hi
love at first sight you guys
wow Clank pretty sure you're me after
all wait
it's not me I mean come on I yeah you
got nothing
he's messing with Clank no
oh that's right they've never met either
dude are we gonna get some like
Cooperative kind of missions now
AJ draws dude what is up AJ
welcome thank you so much for becoming a
channel member
you guys follow me on Twitter AJ
actually Drew my profile picture on
Twitter
some really amazing artwork from AJ very
very talented AJ thank you so much
enjoy the emotes dude
emotes Emoji we actually unlocked four
more new ones thanks to last night's
stream so
I gotta get on that getting some more
designed
dude I think we're actually close to the
end
[Music]
oh love you too AJ thanks for all the
support be my guest
wait is Merlin broken or is it just
showing okay there we go now Merlin's
showing up
oh my gosh wait this is this final boss
okay we have void Repulsor oh no I I
thought they'd taken away all our items
all right so let's immediately get
oh my gosh that was a big hit let's
immediately get Mr fungi going let's
also get the glove of Doom guys out
and then he moves pretty quick I'm gonna
get the shatter blast going on here
as we just leveled up
all right he's at 80 he's got
I don't think we're damaging him right
now at all
what is happening oh my goodness
here we go dude
oh
okay wait am I supposed to fight him
what is happening
okay hold on hold on hold on there we go
there we go we're good we're good
oh dude that is so cool
all right so hold on let's get Mr fungi
back out again
and let's hit him with a pixelizer
boom this one's just fun look at that
oh wait he's already transformed back
well let's see I feel like the executor
maybe that one will do well on him
this one's like the shotgun style blast
he does a lot of damage too
We need oh no desperately need some help
wait what
oh I think I landed on
okay for real can I have a moment can I
have a moment please
James what is up dude
James welcome my friend
this was just a completely impromptu
I I was like dude I kind of want to play
some ratchet and
I think I might want to chat with some
people while I'm playing it let's just
go live
let's just go live for a random stream
oh dude this is my favorite weapon but
it is not doing a great job on him
though
guys if you don't already follow James
if your Hogwarts like it's a band I
think most of you in here right now
probably know James already and follow
James over at expecto go but if not
check out his YouTube channel he has
some amazing Hogwarts Legacy videos
the father of the Hogwarts Legacy Merlin
Theory
dude we are just getting uh wrecked
right now I don't really know oh okay
hold on let's try our new weapon the
warmonger
yep that's not gonna work well because
you got to be very precise
all right well
okay the other one we can try the void
repulser dude he just like 12.
oh that actually works on him
okay let's see if it blocks those okay
it does not block those I didn't expect
it to because that's kind of like an
area of effect
all right I'm in the air why does that
hit me
I I know I could Dodge him guys I'm just
like
I'm trying to focus on what weapons are
going to work best against him
let's see negatron collider is going to
be hard to hit
I feel like we should just get a bunch
of these guys out
and a bunch of the
Mr Fung guys out
[Music]
and then probably hit him with
I mean the executor you kind of got to
be close for that one but he does keep
charging me like that
oh yeah we're doing damage quick to him
now we just gotta
[Music]
oh my God dude
hey high IQ Warrior dude what instant
hit
thanks for hanging out hi Q Warrior have
a good night
uh let's get these guys out again like
he's just all over me this time dude
and I don't think there's anywhere to
get health in this area either
uh
let's try lightning rod
oh is that wait is that stunning him
oh this is perfect
oh
that little barricade messed me up
I had a good little Pace going
all right let's get Mr fungi back out oh
we already got him at 50 come on
come on come on come on
I feel like he's gonna start sending us
to another dimension here shortly
yep what'd I tell you
he's at 50 now oh but I see some health
right here
oh we grabbed it just in time dude
we grabbed it just in time I'm so sorry
guys I know there's a lot of comments
I'm trying to keep up with him too it's
so different James if you're still here
this is so different from winard
like when we're doing a dedicated talk
show where the intent is to only talk to
chat
this one is so different where I also
have like the game to concentrate on now
these guys we fought a bunch of them
the shatter blast works very well
against them if I could actually hit it
yeah look at that man
Big Time damage and actually you know
what else I bet will work well is this
warmonger
oh dude that was crazy damage
oh man maybe that's the play here
just wait and try to line up that
perfect shot
that hit him I don't know if it hit him
or not
all right we're gonna get he's already
36 so I think one of them definitely hit
him
all right hit Mr fungi out again which
we are out of him put the glove of Doom
out and back to the lightning rod
out of lightning rod all right let's
just go with the normal pistol for a bit
it's got kind of a nice spread on it
he had the same idea that's what he
started using
oh here we go all right we got him 25
it's time again
time to transport again
okay we're back here
dude that did so much Damon all right
glove of Doom glove of Doom
yikes we're already 18 that was a big
hit
there's so much going on man
and I don't think I have any more oh we
did we did replenish our lightning rod
ammo let's go
I have no idea how to dodge this
oh we need more Mr fun guys though
and Megatron colliders just
so tough to hit
actually it's not when he does that
though
I think if we get hit one more time we
might be done
okay I've got one warmonger
let's go Direct Hit Direct Hit switch to
the blast pistol
come on two percent one percent one
percent one percent one percent
there it is chat there it is
David how's it going JP raven fire here
as well
Jake heading out for the night I think
I don't know if Jake's still here Jake
was that or no I think Jake was saying
good night to uh high IQ Warrior
I don't know about that interactable
Harry Potter wand
any of you guys getting it I watched the
trailer for it again today
it popped up in my recommended I was
like sure I'll watch this again
oh dude wait what is happening now is
this the one from the other dimension oh
oh no
[Laughter]
no
the fake out
JP don't talk much even when I'm not
playing games never played a ratchet
clink they're fun dude they're fun games
here sooner however and hold on did we
get another uh we got another member
here Violet anxiety was that a gifted
I didn't even hear it pop up I was so In
the Heat of battle sorry that I missed
that violent anxiety thank you so much
for your support
and becoming a channel member here you
just unlocked some new
or wait is that a sub
I can't tell if it's a suburb membership
since I missed it already
but regardless thanks so much for
showing your support to the channel
[Music]
too expensive you do want it though
tantalizing why don't we make this
interesting a home game okay wait so
what is he gonna do with him
are they gonna
okay wait so that's
you
interesting
Pierre he'll take you to him
oh so they're splitting back up all
right so it's I was thinking we were
about to shift into end game right there
oh so now we got rivet
and I guess ratchet is back together
with Clank now I love it I love it
all right so let's see what all we have
we unlocked any cool new armor
the armor in this game is so slick man
and you can actually change up the uh
oh that one would be cool but I don't I
don't like putting any of them on unless
I have the whole set like that one
that's the whole set but I'm just not
I'm not a big fan of that one
I don't know it actually looks cooler
when it's
equipped right there
all right let's go back here and then
they also have little uh little perks
and things and then you can change the
color too so that one's I'm not a fan of
that one G-Force this is the one I had
this one right here
and for rivet we were rocking the purple
dude this one would be really cool but I
want the robot pirate helmet to go with
it I could do the Wasteland helmet with
it though
and not a huge fan of that one either
honestly the helmets I don't really like
any of the helmets except for
carbon Ox that's definitely the coolest
helmet
all right we're just gonna go back with
that for now
only thing you're spending money uh
anything on is Hogwarts Legacy
did you go uh Deluxe or did you go
collector's edition
all right so earlier there was a bunch
of stuff in here let's see if we
unlocked any more of these
oh nice we did so we unlocked the silver
these were actually really tough
they were really tough and so it looks
like if we do so you get 4 000 for that
5 000 for that and for this one you get
one
of the gold bolts defeat 50 pests before
the poison gas kills you all right I'm
going for that one
I'm going for that one
all right so my thought immediately
all right immediately throw out the Mr
fungi's
and also get a bunch of these glove of
Dooms out
and then we're gonna go with lightning
rods because that one just
oh but they're actually spreading out
though the lightning Rod's good because
it has that chaining effect
how many did we have to 50 50 is what we
need to take out
why am I taking damage like I don't see
the gas anywhere is it just constantly
around us
that might be what's going on it might
be constantly around us
dude look at all these little
all right let's get Mr strong guy back
out
oh we're out of lightning rod
that's like my go-to man
uh honestly probably blast pistol
we're at 25 too we need more Health
there it is right there perfect timing
only took us up to 40 though
all right they're doing such a good job
oh we've already got 49.50 oh we look at
that let's go let's go
have I played Destroy All Humans at all
I have never played Destroy All Humans
no
so was godric Gryffindor
a Gryffindor in a hat wait what do you
wait wait I'm not following AJ wait so
was godric a was Godzilla Gryffindor a
lion in it maybe mean a lion and a hat
all right let's do
freezer pop to feed 25 Frozen amoeboids
oh a cat in hat gotcha
gotcha
going Deluxe haven't bought yet saving
up for it nice nice
hey if you win that 25 Amazon card JP
that would be that could go toward it
all right let's do survive five waves
Against The Mangler
I love how ratchet handles Collectibles
too I forgot I should have showed you
all how the uh what that gold boat gold
bolt got me
all right you guys know my the drill by
now it's just kind of like instantly
we're gonna throw out some of the Mr
fungi
can I take this thing out I wonder
or do I just have to
survive it and take out the other
enemies
[Music]
okay that's wave one yeah I think we're
just supposed to survive with him out
here
where are they at where they at where
they at right there
and then another Mr fungi I need to save
him though because I think we have to
I think it's at five rounds that we're
trying to survive
oh my gosh dude this just the sheer
amount of
Mayhem on screen
I'm playing on the performance mode too
so the frame rate just stays
60 FPS it's glorious
glorious
yeah can you imagine the game can
actually look better than this guys on
the Fidelity mode
give me that frame rate though give me
that silky smooth frame rate oh my gosh
something just appeared right behind me
hey back off
and let's go ahead and get another Mr
fungi out
oh I didn't mean to put out two
all right that's wave three I think it's
what two more waves
wave four
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
dude
wonder what if they did a Hogwarts
Legacy PS5
oh my gosh
I mean normally I would I would say not
a chance but because of how heavily
Sony has been involved with the game oh
I only have one glove of Doom left I
better save it
I gotta make it I gotta survive one more
round
we're gonna need at least one glove of
Doom for that
all right we're already gonna be without
Mr fungi
unless this one is still hanging around
all right let's go ahead and get on the
glove of Doom right away
throw those out there and okay we got a
little bit of lightning rod left
let's go ahead and use it
and we're at roughly half of our health
so we're still okay
foreign
oh there's more Mr fun guy right there
all right let's go
and back to the executor
I gotta say sometimes it's hard to
distinguish the Allies from the the
enemies like these little guys
especially the little guys with the
razor blades not these guys they're
pretty easy to tell
these guys right here
they look so much like those other
little dude I'm running out of
everything
[Applause]
Victory there we go
well the first time I did these it was
hard but
now I think we've got so many upgrades
it's making it a little bit easier we'll
see what these next couple ones are like
Arkham's character trophies are the
coolest collectibles in a game love
rotating the character models
I got the platinum trophy in I think it
was Arkham Asylum I think the first one
maybe the second one too I love those
games
I love the Arkham games
Smash Brothers always did a good job of
having the uh wait
oh my gosh I only have I only have the
war Monger defeat four waves of enemies
using the warmonger only have six
missiles with it
okay let's
well the good thing is it does a lot of
damage
but oh no we're already at 30 health
and then wait what do we do okay it
automatically replenished my ammo I was
about to get concerned about that
no
okay all right this one might be a hard
one
this one might be a hard one
Jake with the two months you're right
Jake thank you so much for continuing to
be a member here and part of our
community on YouTube what what's this
wait what do you what do you mean what's
this the game
was this the game
or what's your membership
all right so now we know we just need to
immediately start firing since we don't
have to worry about Ammo
wait should I just
hold on hold on
did we just figure out a little hack
right here
I'm cool with this I'm cool with this
I'm cool with just living right here
oh no
oh my gosh then it did 15 damage
okay so it works but we've got to be
careful about
we gotta make sure that we stay right
over the center of it
oh no we're out of ammo why are we out
of ammo
I thought it automatically replenished
oh I think we gotta break this
all right do we have ammo now
there we go
oh no
okay hold on use this
we're out of ammo again
right when I got over there
and we're at three HP that's not good
dude that is the that is the cheat code
though
just to hang out over there I'm gonna
die because I can't get to the ammo
over there and blast you over there
oh my gosh we're still like
dang it dude
oh
you clicked on the middle do I get it
every month
wait did you do it by accident
that's a good question for I think I
think when you become
a member I think it Auto renews
I think it Auto renews
like five dollars each month but I feel
like it should have some sort of
confirmation there
I don't think it should activate from
just clicking the button
all right we're back here we're back
here again
oh they actually got me that time even
though I was out here
bouncing on this
dude like it is just almost impossible
to avoid these guys when you're
and now I'm out of ammo again
it'd be so much easier if you had
unlimited ammo
no
are you kidding me that does so much
damage when you fall in there
yeah I'm totally out of ammo right now
okay there it is over there
you get that metal notification when you
get a new badge
oh okay so but the the YouTube
membership unless you're gifted
it is set to Auto renew I believe right
or do you have to manually do it each
month Nico
I feel like it's Auto and you can like
you could turn that off if you wanted to
but uh what Nico's talking about are the
what they call like loyalty badges
so I have them set up to where oh we're
so dead dude
we're so dead where they will uh they
like change color based on how long
you've been a member yeah if we are
going
dude this one's tough man all right I'm
gonna skip over that one I'm gonna try
to
I'm gonna try to defeat the 25 Frozen me
boys
and then we'll go back to that one
[Music]
because you have to beat them all to
unlock the final one here in the silver
category
I think it's Auto new gotcha okay okay
all right oh we only have one thing
and I actually don't even have this
weapon unlocked I didn't pay for it
so it looks like they give it to you
automatically for
just for this
now I probably won't keep it after this
challenge
oh my gosh like see like
that is so ridiculous that you can run
out of ammo
oh no
not good not good
icicles destroyed okay so that's all we
have to worry about
all right oh you can get a bunch right
here
thank you oh here we go this should be
it this should be it one more
no
no we're out of ammo
oh my gosh not like this
not like this
destroy there we go
that was too close
it will auto renew by default the
payment can be set to manual
ah gotcha gotcha okay you got the box
breaker what in the world
hold on hold on I did not read what that
said something about square and X
we gotta go into our menu here see if we
can read about this
the Box breaker
to be under gadgets yes here it is okay
a device that when integrated into
oversized Hammers and wrenches extends
the range and power of ground slams it
even allows the user to pick up Bolts
from a greater distance oh my gosh that
is slick right there let's go
that is slick
Shannon welcome Shannon thank you so
much
I can't see if the I need to change what
stream element says I because I can't
see if these people are
subscribing or if they're becoming
members
Oh either way though Shayna welcome
thank you so much retro can't wait until
every Hogwarts streamer puts their title
as episode one
episode one of Hogwarts Legacy
all right break a sweat indeed because
all right so we have to do pest control
that's the one that we were having
trouble with
uh no it was this one Kaboom stick blast
we have to do that one to unlock
the final mystery one here
this one was tough
I feel like movement is the key we gotta
move around a lot
lots of movement
and then we've got to be constantly
aware
of
where the uh ammo boxes are
like see okay we just ran out of ammo
all right there's one
and we gotta be able to utilize that too
okay
oh see we run out at the worst times
what you're still up no way
all right here we go next wave next wave
[Music]
are you serious come on
no no no no no no
oh man they've got a lot of shots
they're firing at me
dude
not not right now
okay we got that one off our back but
we're already at 30 HP and we're out of
ammo again
like I said dude if you didn't run out
of ammo
it'd be so much easier
no
oh okay I need to I need to look here
what do we exactly have to do four waves
of enemies you're right
Jesus
hey red fox we do not know that yet we
do not know
dude they even get back up
after a direct hit
oh no I just
like see we run out of ammo too fast
anything
I was just experimenting with with melee
a bit this time
see if it works any better it does not
I mean warmonger is really strong but
I don't even know why I completed the
wave I'm not gonna beat it
I'm not gonna beat it with 3 HP I can
tell you that
[Music]
foreign
I guess it's good practice though
and who knows me I was gonna say maybe
if we defeat this wave that we will uh
if we are going to go on the emperor get
better
yet another thing of Health
hey thanks for stopping by AJ have a
good one and thanks for becoming a
channel member again very much
appreciate it dude
good to chat with you hope you have a
good evening good morning whatever it
may be where you're at in the world
okay this this first wave
I feel like yep I feel like you almost
have to do that one without getting hit
and I just got oh my gosh dude
how why do they rush over here to me
yeah just go I'm just just go ahead
just go ahead
just end it just end it how am I how am
I still alive
okay there we go
years going by pretty fast already in
October right
yeah I knew I knew it would
hit I knew it was gonna feel
I mean like once December gets here guys
we are at that point it's it's so close
it's so close
and things always kind of uh
they speed up around the hall at least
they speed up around the holidays for me
but you want them to slow down because
it's like time with family for a lot of
people
a lot of people take extra time off work
okay how are you still up
I should not have went in for the melee
just trying to preserve some of the ammo
and we're already at 30. I don't think
there's any
chance to replenish your health on this
at all
plus plus we already know we're gonna
get a big gameplay showing
before the end of the year
dude those guys take two hits as well
that is the thing I am just I am super
looking forward to that
because to me that is going to tell us
so so much like see I have no choice I
have to get I have to get close right
there because I'm out of ammo that's
where all the ammo is
there as many resources as we can
hmm you know what the solution here
could be
the solution could be oh I can't see it
right now the solution could be
upgrading this warmonger
[Music]
because I just unlocked it
so while it is powerful already oh my
gosh I'm I'm missing so many what
oh there's like so many easy shots
okay good to know there's no area of
effect damage on me for my own weapon
even though I blast them at Point Blank
Range
yeah we're gonna get two more asmrs for
sure
gonna get a big gameplay reveal
when do you guys think we're getting the
gameplay real you think it's gonna be my
prediction is either the Sony a Sony
state of play some sort of Sony event
before the end of the year
yeah we already hit the arena
how do I get out of this place
how do we get out of here or it could be
game awards game awards is my other
other thought
oh yeah over here I thought this is
where we get out
I love this whole area this whole area
just looks so cool all right now can we
check our weapons yes we can okay so the
solution might be
to upgrade the war Monger because it is
not oh wait we need a Miss zircon
why can I not see a map right now
dimensions falling apart or pretty sure
there's a Miss Zircon out here
pretty sure there she is
all right let's talk to her oh we just
unlocked that one too okay let's see a
preview of that
Hogwarts Legacy and steam deck we'll see
we'll see
they haven't said anything officially
yet
okay now let's preview this wait why is
it not
it's not let me preview
preview it from here
but that beauty
what it's glitching I think it's
glitching it's not letting me
it's not letting me preview it why
settle for one bomb when you could have
mini to play a drone that flies in a
straight line and drops bombs as it goes
for upgrades when you level that up
interesting okay so the one that we need
to upgrade though is the war Monger oh
and we already have more slots unlocked
let's go all right I'm gonna go straight
over here first that oh yeah this is
gonna make a big difference guys that
increases the area of effect
these are shooting at a higher fire rate
and then we also oh look at that
increased our max ammo
direct hits do more damage oh yeah oh
yeah that's gonna make a big difference
that's gonna make a big difference okay
all right I'm gonna go back in there and
try it right now even though it's not
fully
it's not fully maxed out if I can't beat
it after a couple tries then I'll go on
to the next level and we'll we'll come
back when we have that weapon fully
upgraded
because I feel like that will make a big
difference when it's fully upgraded
we're probably not even I don't know
maybe halfway right now
all right let's see right there it is
oh gameplay reveal on Christmas
that's a good idea
heading to bed oh 6 a.m yikes
that is some that is an early hour right
there
all right all right all right
nice and slow here make sure we're
taking cover
oh no I just lost some of my cover
oh dude we just leveled it up again
let's go that means if we can't beat it
this time oh I walked right into that
one I did
darn it dude I botched that
if we can't beat it this time then we
already have another upgrade unlocked so
that's good
[Music]
yeah maybe we need to pay a closer
attention to exactly where they're
emerging from
and just immediately get the blast on
them
all right let's go over here come on we
gotta get more
oh I feel like the ammo's popping out
quicker now too
and we're already at wave three let's go
okay we're out now
to everyone from over there
oh dude the last wave is gonna be insane
because this wave is already crazy
all right we just got more right there
let's go dude let's go
come on come on come on
no a boss
wait wait wait
this might be the Strat never mind
hey that got him down to 70 though
[Applause]
oh we need more ammo
come on come on come on
no what are you
oh no dude
no we're out of ammo at the worst time
okay he's gone but do we have to defeat
these guys too
we do
oh
and we're out of ammo
[Music]
oh my gosh that's painful
oh that is painful but
I know we can do it now I know we can do
it JP I'm thinking fall ASMR in October
gameplay and sixth uh oh the character
creative tab in November winter ASMR in
December
think Hogwarts Legacy for switch is
gonna be for the switch Pro dude I still
don't even know if there's gonna
actually be a switch Pro it's been
rumored for years now
it's been rumored for years although
there there's definitely something
weird going on with the switch version
but I can't I mean they're gonna have to
put it out on the current switch they
have to because they've already I mean
they've committed to that
multiple times they've committed to it
so I think even if there happens to be a
switch pro at some point Hogwarts Legacy
has committed to running on the current
switch dude I can't take a hit right
there on this first little
wave
wave oh already out of ammo come on dude
I should have just went back and
upgraded it a little bit more before I
even attempted this
and I also need to be more mindful of my
my cover and not wasting it
like I just blasted it right there
oh dude that's perfect when they're all
when they're
coming out of the same spot right there
all right we need ammo we need ammo
Direct Hit and you're still
okay three out of eight five out of
eight
I should also probably try to keep a
better eye on my ammo how much I have
all right we're out
okay we're at three right now okay one
two
three okay I'm gonna grab some more oh
we went right into that though
no 15.
uh and this is the craziest wave too
[Applause]
all right
oh that's totally on me
that is totally on me
just a guy enjoyed this game far too
short completed about eight hours yeah
I've been stretching it out so I've just
been I've been playing it over the span
of a couple months probably just playing
like an hour or two a week so
and I'm loving these little challenges
too oh wait before I I almost just
immediately retried let me go and
upgrade that weapon again and then I
think it's gonna be
because that alone upgrading at the one
time made a huge huge difference now
upgrading it again I think will be in in
good shape played it directly after
return I felt like
I don't know about downgrade but
definitely in terms of a difficulty I
could certainly see what you mean there
big uh step down in the difficulty for
sure
okay wait where'd it go
warmonger there it is all right so we
have six spots that we can update so we
definitely want to do this and this
because then it upgrades oh homing
homing Rockets now let's
go Rockets lock on the enemy targets
that is going to be great to have
direct hits do more damage yeah I
definitely want that one
shots at a higher rate might as well do
everything increase the area of effect
so we only have one upgrade left but
that's we've upgraded everything we have
unlocked at this point
so anyway all right back in we go
returnal's awesome though I I really
enjoy eternal it took me a bit it it
took me a bit to for it to click
and I'm a huge house Mark fan I love
Resogun is one of my favorite games ever
I played that game so much at the launch
of PS4
super Stardust though enjoyed that one
as well Outland I was a big fan of
it is not your fault yeah Eternal is
awesome and there's there's been rumors
of that one coming to PC I maintain if
that game ever comes to PC I feel like
it will be so much easier
I feel like it will be so much easier
with mouse and keyboard I mean if you
have that pinpoint
aim
I just feel like it will make such a big
difference
dude come on
it really hurts when you take a hit on
this first wave
because the first wave is the easiest
oh dude these homing Rockets though
let's go
we did not increase our ammo though
unfortunately
all right where are they at where they
at where are they at right there
all right two more
there's one there's two all right we
gotta go find ammo now
there we go
I might as well go ahead and grab it
over here as well take the little bounce
two more shots
all right that wave's done but we need
ammo again
like even if it just gave you a little
more time between each wave
to get your ammo ready to go
oh my gosh it is insane right now
totally insane
no oh I'm out of ammo that's why I just
took a hit
all right wave three down let's go
all right here's the big guy
okay we got four
no I came down at the worst possible
time what
wait the middle thing disappears if we
are going to face the emperor we should
gather as many resources
I guess it disappears for the final
round
all right well
well we'll have to remember that
it is coming to PC yeah I keep hearing
that
I just feel like whenever people play
that on mouse and keyboard they're gonna
be like oh people thought this game was
hard
and we just leveled it up again or no we
leveled up uh ratchet leveled up which
is a great timing oh because we just
took two direct hits
so now we're only at 40 health
I don't care though we're beating it
this time
two hits already or not I'm locking in
locking in folks
okay we're out we're out we're out we
gotta move we gotta move
fire yeah I know it's out of ammo I'm
trying
I'm trying
no out of ammo again
okay let's just try to do a little ammo
run here
oh gosh that was my aim was so off on
that one oh and I took a hit as a result
of it that's unfortunate my
my hand I'm gonna go with my hands
slipped as my excuse for that one
oh
no dude
oh my gosh
Tom how's it going dude welcome yeah
doing well man doing well
doing a little impromptu
Ratchet and Clank stream here in the
late night hours
I wasn't sleepy and I wanted to play
some games and I thought you know what
why not stream this
so here we are
and this is actually a
I didn't anticipate really going after
these challenges but
anytime there's something that poses a
little bit of difficulty
it makes me want to do it even more so
here we are
okay we did just upgrade it again right
there but it doesn't even matter because
we only had one
upgrade or Crystal
to use anyway so
one two
three missiles I've used four
five
six I don't think I even needed to shoot
that one all right we got three more
[Applause]
two and three okay let's grab these
right here
no you moved at the last second
and then and then you moved again oh
my gosh why could it not just refill me
all the way
these little one and
two refills are not helping
foreign
I panicked and did that little Dash
because I
I thought I'd undershot it
okay two missiles
no no no no no
I feel like if I can get okay I was
about to say if I can get to the final
wave
at 37.
all right there he is
oh yeah oh yeah
okay gotta go get ammo now
all right we're at six
see that's the thing about him you also
have to really make sure you keep your
eye on him I wasn't expecting him to do
it that quickly
no no no no no no no
you will not stop the emperor's vision
no we need one more missile please
let's go oh my gosh
finally dude oh so satisfying explosions
chaos and violence
indeed we finally got it though but that
wasn't even the that wasn't even the
final thing we just unlocked that now
so this is the silver tier
so by completing all four of those
we unlocked this one revenge of the
Seeker peed defeat scolo the secret
I have not played Kana and I just heard
they had a big update so it might be a
good time to to jump in and play that
one
love the art style I think it looks I
think it looks great
I I it was on my list but like like I
was saying earlier in the Stream my
backlog is just ridiculous right now
it's crazy it's it's so crazy how many
games I want to play and haven't
but that's what happens man when you
have kids and you have a side job that
you're that you're really into
that's what happens but if I could do
more streams like this like
these kind of late night more low-key
not as planned like not worry about the
webcam and the lighting and all that
oh my gosh
okay wait do I have all my weapons all
right that's good I do have all my
weapons
throw out a couple of these Mr fun guys
and then dude I'm just gonna go this war
Monger is
pretty powerful let's go with that
I don't even know if shooting him
underneath hurts hurts him or not
all right shatter blast is pretty good
too
of course he moved right when I
oh okay that was new
all right throw up Mr fungi again and
let's get some of these
glove of Doom guys going I don't even
know if they're gonna help me because
they
whoa is he just what the heck
hey just upgraded the glove of Doom
there we go starting to stun him with
that but I I knew we were about to run
out man I knew we were
he's only at 50 yikes
all right we need to get some oh man I
wasted two my Mr fun guys
I wonder if his like head is the weak
point or
I've kind of been aiming at that little
blue spot on the front but maybe it's
the head right there
or maybe he doesn't really have a weak
point maybe just just hit him
okay we're out of that one now too we're
running out of all our our weapons
oh come on come on Ratchet you could
throw that further
farther
[Music]
all right 25 percent
I don't really like how that that wasn't
feeling too great
okay we're out of War Monger now as well
oh we got another Mr fungi though
backlog is huge as well just not the
time I know dude there's just so many
good games
Oh I thought I jumped
[Music]
Miss fungal wait what
oh there we go let's go dude
okay that was way easier than the last
one
the last one was really tough okay we
unlocked the carbonics advanced chest
which I think
I'm pretty sure the one that I'm already
wearing is the carbonics
I believe so anyway yeah all right so we
completed bronze we completed silver and
gold we haven't unlocked yet so I guess
we have to progress further in the game
all right nice okay so let's make our
way outside and actually hold on I don't
even think we have to make our way
outside yeah so carbonics Advanced
that's what I already had on
so now we get uh extra 10 for bolts
gained
wearing this
yeah I don't think it's
double checking to make sure that was
the right one
yeah it'd be kind of cool if it gave you
I don't know some sort of other uh
I mean we can change the color but
that's already been
and then we need a third there's one
more check mark over there
one more check mark something else to
upgrade an upgraded carbonics chest
plate now with synthetic Alloys from an
even darker timeline
ah
all right I don't even know what our our
new objective says either oh we gotta
wait till we
get out here okay wait still not far
enough
oh yeah you have to go through this door
right here
I have not played Hades either I've
watched that being streamed and being
played though
and it is definitely a game I would
enjoy for sure
for sure I can tell you I would enjoy
Hades
if I ever get the time for it
all right Miss fungal I thought it was
Mr fungi what the heck
I do use that one quite a bit we only
have nine upgrade spots though
and warmonger is pretty strong
upgraded him quite a bit glove of Doom
I've been using that one a lot
so lightning rod
is fully upgraded for right now
shatterblast is fully upgraded executors
fully upgraded Ricochet I don't really
use that so I haven't even worried about
it all right so yeah I mean I guess
maybe we should focus on uh
let's do glove of Doom
the glove of Doom
I'm not gonna spin everything though I'm
gonna hold back save a little bit anyway
save a little bit okay so our next
objective we've done everything here we
defeated Dr nefarious
collectibles
we did unlock uh oh I forgot to even
come to this menu and check and see what
I unlocked earlier here we go head size
oh my gosh
tiny big or default okay I gotta see
this what
oh my goodness dude
that is just weird
now he's the size of or she's the size
of the
oh I forget the robot's name on my back
right now
completely forgot her name
the photo mode and Ratchet was very well
done right yeah it was insanely well
done
okay let's go back to I don't like the
big head mode at all what is RPG oh you
can show the numbers yeah I'll leave the
numbers off
now but now we gotta see
it's like a bobble head
oh that's so funny
okay so there's that one I'm just gonna
put it back on normal then there's the
wrench swap pack oh my goodness dude
those are really cool right there
goon sword goon Hammer pirate sword
swordfish or key
just gonna go default here and then
Hammer pack swap
wait what wrench swap
oh you see you can have the wrench or
the hammer be those things I was waiting
for a different category
and then oh yeah I'm not worried about
all those entries
not worried about all those
all right let's see where we're supposed
to head next here
times
and then it's probably gonna shift over
to ratchet at some point too we didn't
see what ratchet's up to
Okay so we've done everything we can do
here right now because we don't have the
gold one unlocked yet we are still
missing three Collectibles over there on
the right so now we have two planets
that we've unlocked The sargasso Outpost
l51 and then this one ardolis pirate
base
he'll help you warn Captain Quantum so
this one here it says stop the emperor's
Invasion rivet and kit kit that's the
name of this robot rivet and kit need to
help the Morts fight off the emperor's
Invasion and this one here says
Ratchet and Clank must find Captain
Quantum before the emperor does that one
sounds more like in-game-esque to me so
I'm gonna do this one
people are now just waiting for
Wolverine oh my gosh right
oh
we haven't seen anything
later but just knowing it's insomniac
that's enough for me to be pumped
for sure
is an alternate Dimension you although
it will be interesting like to see how
you know because Wolverine he control or
should control totally different from
Spider-Man yeah they're really good with
traversal you think of like Sunset
Overdrive and Spider-Man ratchet like
that fluid movement of a character
nah you guys should keep working
together come on
you guys can keep working together after
we finish all this
so yeah how are like what's going to be
Wolverine I mean of course you'll be
able to run fast but like what's gonna
be his fun kind of
traversal mechanic
a whole game from insomniacs dude
somebody needs to try to make another
good hole
hey can we talk about this over some
lemonade
my kids they love uh they love the
Marvel superheroes Games the Lego ones
my youngest is a big Hulk fan he likes
Hulk just
the pure just destruction
my oldest is more of a an Iron Man
kind of kid
all right so what is our objective here
defend the Morts okay
and we still have let's see if we have
any Collectibles here oh just one one
gold bolt so there is one
bolt that we're missing could
potentially be in this area or in one of
these areas looks like those are
unexplored
but right now we just need to worry
about this here
all right so what do we say here let's
go with a little lightning rod let's
start
I just love the movement of these games
man it's so good
okay those are good guys over there
Empress horses are here for us
oh these were the things I was just
fighting on that on that challenge
see they're not too bad when I have
plenty of ammo
and let's go back to just our regular
pistol finish this guy off
oh wait you guys are good
you guys are good
oh there's one over here
[Music]
all enemies neutralized oh that means
neutralize all right nicely done
for now let's go talk to Morton find out
what's going on
you are just the best
okay defend the more space is is there
anything else we need to do
walk over to them here
we've tried to hold our own fixed up the
secret bead and everything but one of
those dimensional thingamajiggers is
blocking it from taking off first off
none of this was your fault
second lead the thingamajigger to us
say hi to kit
free the secret
what in the world
and looks like this is going to take us
somewhat in this at least in this
direction
over here I don't know
helper bot that will lead us to the
Seeker feed
okay this definitely looks like a case
for the glove of Doom guys right here
and what do you think maybe another
lightning rod
lighting rods just kind of my go-to for
the mobs
I love the area of effect on it
all right you guys made short work of
them
yeah they're all these bolts over here
okay
oh yeah this is gonna take us right over
there
okay so I know it's kind of like in-game
or getting close to in-game so it's sort
of pushing me to hurry through
but I also want to see
these aliens are from Minnesota
wait what's why would they uh what's the
story there
for a hologram Minnesota got some aliens
or something
okay free the secret feeds still our
only objective all right
we need to be on the lookout for a gold
bolt guys
they're usually pretty well hidden
so because I think let's see yeah one
gold bowl and that's that's it that's
the only thing that I'm still missing
from this
playing it
we'll see how you feel so that's why I'm
gonna go around here look on this side
nothing there
are accents oh gotcha
these little dudes right here
these little guys
all right gold bolt gold Bolt
there's a lot of like yellows and greens
in this area so they're gonna be even
harder to spot
[Music]
oh we're kind of going the opposite way
it looks like we need to go
to get over there to that area
I know they're kind of pushing me the
other way but
I don't think we can get there from
where we're at right now
I think we need a different traversal
mechanism
foreign
this little bot right here
right right the snails yeah yeah
I knew there was something
that I could use on this planet
which I don't know if they're even
available in this little Mission or not
must be
also wait we do that we have a Mr fungi
and a miss fungal
maybe it's because ratchet and rivet
were able to meet up then
yes start going our way it will
just kind of look it around just looking
around
checking the map too
oh my gosh I just love how much happens
on screen at once
it's so ridiculous
in the best way possible
oh they took him out
hey what is
looks like something shot me from over
there
yeah it's good good to upgrade the
lightning strike we use this one a lot
honestly I kind of use it as it's sort
of my my default
unless you have something a little
larger you want to try to do a little
bit more damage
so like if they're up close you can go
executor if they're far away I go
negatron or now we've got this warmonger
which does pretty well
especially now that it has the Homing
capabilities
but then like these guys over here it's
like definitely the lightning strike
oh then we got some over here too
alrighty then
I'm not really sure which way we're
supposed to go here
where's that guy we're supposed to be
following
oh goodness where did you guys come from
all right this looks like the area like
the way you're not supposed to go so I'm
just gonna
collect these bolts and see if there's
anything else to collect over here
looks like no
unless we go all the way over but then
that just takes us back there okay
[Music]
oh I didn't see that there what jump
[Music]
okay here's some health over here
definitely need that
the controls in this game are really
good too they they really did a good job
taking advantage of the
of the Dual sense all right you guys are
being annoying up in the air so
I'm gonna shotgun you
okay now you're going back further away
so we're gonna switch
oh nefarious Juggernaut and of course
right the moment that we
lose a bunch of our health
all right let's get the oh I see that I
see that
let's get the uh Miss fungi out there
or Miss fungal
get the glove of Dooms going
to just like the constant stagger right
now
and then you know what let's try to get
some more Monger shots in while he's
locked in place right there
oh I almost missed it I almost didn't
jump in time
oh dude I don't like this
I don't like this
no I was too busy trying to change
weapons
uh
[Music]
are you serious we have to do all these
again before the
before the boss comes out that giant
robot
dude these actually take quite a bit of
uh
quite a few hits right here
all right let's go I'm ready for it
no okay forget that lightning strike we
lightning strike it is okay there's the
Juggernaut all right
wow I'm doing so bad
uh oh you know what void Repulsor might
actually be good against him but
let's do that run out of energy too fast
in Hogwarts mystery
only three one choices
no I jumped too soon
oh I'm getting too tired that's the
problem
okay
let's focus let's focus we got this we
got this
as I jump right into one
why are you throwing them so far ratchet
come on there you go right in front of
you
back to the blast pistol
all right now right when he emerges I'm
gonna go straight to these guys
two Miss fungals
and then instant warmonger and he just
still
all right not that time buddy
not that time
oh he's moving though he's on the Move
he's on the move
or some health
there's some health right there
foreign
Oh I thought I switched to pixelizer
there it is
of course I dodge it and then just fall
right on
nah not void repulser
there we go finally
oh no we gotta back up though
no don't die now don't die right after
we just took him out
no
oh my gosh I dropped my controller
oh
shrewd monkey hey how's it going trude
monkey I think there should be a weapon
wheel for spells and consumable item
yeah that's what we were talking about a
little bit earlier like I really like
the
the wheel and Ratchet I think they do a
good job
with letting you switch between a lot of
different
weapons quickly
all right glove of Doom One Love of Doom
2.
oh we're down to one miss fungal so I'm
Gonna Save that
all right we're at 70 out of 70 right
now
keep it that way as long as we can
man this was just this is kind of the
main weapon it just does not do enough
damage
all right Miss fungal straight at him
second Miss fungal
glove of Doom all right come on I just
want the glove of Dooms going crazy
there's another one
all right now we're gonna go warmonger I
barely dodged it
I did not Dodge that one at all
[Music]
see the problem is we gotta remember
even after we destroyed him last time
then we died to the other guys but we
just refilled our health though let's go
nice okay
all right all right all right we're in
much better shape this time
gotta stay away from those little pools
the pools of electricity
all right back to lightning strike I
feel like
it was indeed
Hazel with Phoenix 13 nice
JP one wood is black walnut trees are
found in your area oh that's cool wait
what are we supposed to do I'm supposed
to go into this now
right
uh oh what just happened
all these crazy puzzles dude
these are actually pretty fun
you remembered your trading okay so that
one Powers them up
to where we can do this
okay then that's blocked right there all
right now
another one to pick up
it does lowers that all right now
they're running this way
I don't know if that's correct
[Music]
all right wait wait wait
that might be the wrong spot for it
we might need to put that one
there
okay so that oh then they don't even
nope nope nope
this right here
nice okay I think we might got I think
we might have it
yeah there we go
have you played Cana bridge I have not
yeah I've heard I've heard a lot of good
things though and I know they just had a
big update
so it might be a good time to jump back
in
for him not to jump back in but to try
it for the first time
[Music]
what does that mean all right so that's
set up there
what do you think of clay we have barely
spoken but okay the question is can I
I make it over here
yes okay good I don't know if we can
make that jump or not but we did
so now we can grab this
all right do you think we should
energize this right here
yeah I didn't think so they can't make
that
energize that over there
and then stand right here
hmm okay maybe not maybe it's this one
here
Perfect all right that turns that
all right so now I wonder if we should
if we take that though yeah we can't
take that one they immediately
they immediately fall and die over there
wait what
I thought I was supposed to okay it
worked that time
all right so if I take it back out of
there
then that oh now this isn't facing the
correct way
hello
I feel like we need that to lower okay
that's what I was gonna say we need this
to lower
and now what happens when I stand on
this
perfect okay that's exactly what we need
now they're running that way so all we
have to do is remove you from here
wait what why are you doing why are you
guys doing that now
and then they just fall straight in
oh it went oh wait I need to stay on it
okay
I have to stay on top of this thing I
believe
I'm pretty sure neat I think Nico's
Ravenclaw
okay then toss it over there
yes there we go
there we go I don't need to jump down
yet though until the door's completely
unlocked
there it is
[Music]
teleport to exit and I think there'll be
one more it'll probably be one more
puzzle that we have to solve
camera was going a little crazy there
all right so
that's what you think this way first oh
dude this area is huge
okay so stepping off of that one makes
you go straight over each other well all
right first we're gonna have to do
something
to address this right here
all right so now they can travel that
way
and that means I can also travel this
way
shrewd monkey we got a Slytherin in the
house uh oh
all right so I don't think I can throw
any of these
you know what I think
I think we need to put it right there
are you serious
all right so I could throw that there
and then that's going to Electrify them
which that's probably what we want
and then what if I stand here
oh can I not grab that one
oh
oh okay I should have carried it with me
no not you
oh that's not the one I wanted
wait it's still
I thought I picked up the red one
I think it was just because of the the
coloration behind it
ah
all right let's grab this one now oh
it's a blue one super heavy energy done
better than I would have if I had been
in your shoes okay super heavy so super
heavy would allow us to
I don't think it's gonna be needed there
I wonder if it would allow them to run
through
okay so they get really heavy right
there
and for your father
helping plant and I navigate all of this
are doing this
and succeeding
go us go us so now they're heavy and
electrified
but that's not gonna help me because
okay I think we might want them to go
back
okay now they're going that way all
right so let's swap you right here
no I don't want the red I want
yeah I want the electric
okay so now they're gonna go that way
all right and then that's what we oh
wait so wait standing right here
standing right here is what triggers
this
so I wonder if they run over it like
that does it then
actually I don't think that's right I
don't think it's right to send them up
there
okay but what I do think could happen is
if we put the heavy
right there does that let them just run
straight through it does okay
that lets them run straight through
take the electricity off
ah
okay so wait how do we get them
oh this is tough this is tough
because what we want to do is we want to
get them to where they
this is it this is it right here
yes
take a left you guys get electrified you
go through nicely done there we go
boom
all right I think that should be the
last one that should be the last little
puzzle area right here
exit through the meta terminal all right
that's where we're going
and now we back
find out who they're messing with don't
you know
don't you know there it is somebody said
they're from Minnesota
thank you
Voldemort ain't all that
not exactly a straight line to the
battle all right take down the various
ships but you know what I think this is
going to be a good stopping point so
oh my gosh it's almost 1 30 my time man
all right my eyes are getting tired I
gotta get some sleep but uh thank you
all who stopped by and
hung out a little bit for tonight's
little impromptu
live stream we'll have to do this again
sometime so
um I I love streaming games I really
enjoy streaming games I just don't get
to do it nearly as often as I would like
but uh everybody who stopped by and was
hanging out for a bit thank you very
much I'll keep this VOD up we'll see
maybe people will be interested in
having the VOD up
and if you guys if you do watch this on
the replay and you enjoy it just shoot
me a comment let me know Down Below in
the comments if you enjoyed this because
it's kind of like a let's play but that
was live streamed and so it can just
still live on YouTube
so uh yeah man thank you all for hanging
out as always thank you all so much for
watching
and I will talk to you again soon Jagged
wizard Elwood oh my gosh L when you were
here the whole time Jagged wizard I
believe that's the first I saw you in
the chat but
hope you got to watch a little bit at
least and I wasn't hopping off right
when you joined but
thank you all so much uh everybody have
a great night and I will talk to you
again soon yeah yeah time to go get some
rest